all right yesterday was um mlk day
lots of democrats of course using mlk to
promote their agenda
but this clip from biden which actually
is from like a year ago uh went viral
again as people were kind of reminiscing
about it and biden is criticized for
saying what he says it's a brief clip
he's criticized for this a lot of people
on the right of course criticizing him
but um i i actually agree with him let's
let's play the clip
but even dr king's assassination did not
have the worldwide impact
that george floyd's
death did
okay so there you go um
martin luther king's death did not have
the the worldwide impact that george
floyd's death had
and like i said a lot of people on the
right very upset about this and uh
upset anew and criticizing him saying
this is a horrible thing to say
he's actually 100 right
now if you look at the full context and
the point he's trying to make about it
he's not right
because he's not just saying that the
death had a greater impact he he's also
justifying he thinks that it ought to
have had a better impact a greater
impact
and when it comes to the ought to he's
obviously wrong about that but as an
observation he's 100 right like
undeniably
that george floyd's death
had a greater um immediate global impact
than
mlk's death
now mlk's life
of course had a much greater impact than
george floyd's life did
george floyd floyd's
life had no impact on society except a
negative one
had a bad impact for his community that
he victimized for the woman that he
robbed at gunpoint when he forced his
way into her house and had a bad impact
for them
but beyond that it had no impact at all
his life was inconsequential
he was a he was a a violent scumbag
criminal
and that's how i'll always describe
anyone who
forces their way into a woman's house
and points a gun at them they're all
scumbags right
so
life life is is one thing life had a
great break but death absolutely george
floyd's death had a greater impact
and that only speaks to how insane
the reaction to george floyd's death was
in fact
it would be hard to think of
if you were to to make a list
of all of the prominent people who've
been who've died
over the last
century
and and we're going to rank whose death
who the the deaths that had the greatest
impact george floyd is in the top three
probably
i mean you probably got jfk and then i i
i think george floyd's probably number
two
and you might even be able to make an
argument for putting him at number one
when you consider just the way that
the the the meltdown i mean the literal
meltdown that occurred across society
and the way that things were reshuffled
and flipped on their heads everything's
upside down and backwards because george
floyd died
let's start with the fact that um
dozens of cities across the country were
in flames for months
and we're still dealing with the effects
of that i mean a total breakdown of law
and order we'll start with that
so the impact was negative
from his death
it's completely
maniacal and irrational and and insane
but did it have a greater impact yeah
in fact i think what the point he makes
there that's the point that we should be
making as conservatives we we shouldn't
be disagreeing with that
we should be pointing that out
because of how crazy it only illustrates
how crazy the reaction was
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated